[Musique]
les comptes administratifs du comité
martiniquais du tourisme ainsi que le
budget de ce satellite de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
au centre de très vives tensions le vote
a eu lieu lundi dernier on a eu de
sérieuses dissensions entre élus de la
majorité la tendance mines du grand
ensemble accusant celle de droite de ba
payant chance de diriger la structure
sans concertation et sans donner d
explications de certaines dépenses
bonjour karine rousseau
bonjour maurizio l'temps bonjour à
toutes et tous vous êtes un présidente
du comité martiniquais du tourisme
semaine difficile pour vous semaine
difficile oui parce qu'on est forcément
déçu quand on n'est pas suivi par ceux
qui sont censés vous soutenir
mais après je dirais que c'est dans les
dents les les étapes difficiles qu'on
grandit oui parce que lorsque les élus
proches du mime ne s'abstiennent pour ce
budget est signal très fort qui qu'on
vous envoie est ce que vous payez là par
exemple votre effort remarque vaut très
fortes critiques vous et yan monplaisir
lors par exemple du budget de
l'assemblée de martinique
écoutez nos moi ce que je veux dire ce
matin c'est que nous sommes bas payés en
chance derrière yens mon plaisir ni dans
le conte comme ni dans le complot ce que
nous voulons c'est travailler faire ce
pourquoi nous avons été élus moi on m'a
donné la responsabilité du comité
martiniquais du tourisme
je suis présidente j'ai donc choisi un
bureau et ça c'est important que les
martiniquaises et les martiniquais
comprennent bien comment fonctionne
l'institution en fait la présidente que
je suis choisi de s'entourer de
personnes pour je dirais la gestion
quasi quotidiennes même si on ne peut
pas physiquement réunir le bureau
quotidiennement donc moins par loyauté
honnêteté
parce que je pense que voilà c'est deux
choses qui me caractérise
j'ai choisi effectivement de mettre à
mon bureau des personnes de l'autre
tendance du grand semblait probable pays
enchanté les termes de l'accord de
décembre 2015
non non c'était pas dans l'accord
j'avais toute liberté de choisir mon
bureau je vous redis aujourd'hui
j'aurais pu très bien mettre à mon
bureau sylviane à issoudun diane
montrose il ya de montplaisir et
marinette torpilles j'aurais pu choisir
de mettre autour de moi ces quatre
personnes qui sont avec moi dans mon
groupe politique
eon qui j'ai pleine confiance entière
confiance et que je connais très bien
parce que nous travaillons ensemble
depuis des années
j'ai par honnêteté loyer d'une loyauté
choisi
de m'entourer de l'autre tendance parce
que nous avions la présidence et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en
divergeant sur un certain nombre de nos
directions à prendre notamment que vous
preniez des décisions que vous vous
dégager des lignes budgétaires sans que
ce bureau et ce concept de la station ne
soit au courant
écoutez les les 250000 euros dont on
parle que l'ag où la campagne 100%
digitale de février alors il s'agit
effectivement de 250000 euros que j'ai
dû engager avant le vote du conseil a
admis du conseil d'administration avant
le vote du budget puisque vous savez
comme moi que la collectivité
territoriale à repousser le vote de son
budget ce qui a fait que j'ai été obligé
de repousser le mien puisque vous ne
pouvez voter votre budget que quand vous
avez la subvention qui vous est
attribuée par la collectivité donc
urgent y avait donc une urgence de
dégager évidemment selon vous vous savez
que le temps touristique n'est pas le
temps politique
nous avons passé depuis début janvier
des moments où il fallait prendre des
décisions pour la prochaine saison
une campagne bat saison que nous avons
fait l'année dernière sous forme
d'affichage dans le métro et les gares
puisque ça fait des années que ça
n'avait pas été fait une campagne bat
saison il faut la faire avant la basse
saison sur les dépenses récurrentes
c'est à dire les dépenses qu'ils
reviennent
nous avons le droit d'engager d'engager
la somme qu'ils étaient
on va dire crédité l'année d'avant c'est
ce que nous avons fait puisque nous
avons engagé cette somme sur la lune
promotion basse saison
oui maintenant sept cette campagne bat
saison c'est une campagne que nous avons
fait sur le web
nous avons choisi de de faire la
promotion à partir de notre film
destination frimo k qui avait déjà pris
un certain nombre de problèmes mais je
finis là dessus parce qu'il faut que les
martiniquais si les martiniquais
comprennent bien que ce film je n'ai
jamais été soutenu par mon bureau pour
ce film que j'ai choisi quand même de
faire parce que ça fait sens de adeline
jetair 6 à ce que la paix n'y a pas eu
d'appel d'offres il découvre ici et il
découvre soudain européenne du conseil
d'administration il découvre que ça va
faire près de 300000 euros
nous nous donnons la parole est à 157
mille euros il y a eu des rallonges
parce que sous la présidence de diane
montrose la commission a travaillé sur
ce film et nous avons rajouté voulu
rajouter des images le film a été primée
aux trophées de cannes
oui nous avons voulu aménager leur fait
des bons choix et moi ce qui est
important c'est que les gens comprennent
bien que le comité martiniquais du
tourisme a une mission c'est de faire
venir des touristes
et tant pis pour les règles de
fonctionnement non les règles de
fonctionnement nous les suivons puisque
de toute façon je ne peux pas engager de
dépenses dans l'illégalité c'est
impossible puisque j'ai avec moi un
comptable et surtout le comptable du
trésor qui évidemment ne peut n'engage
pas des dépenses il n'a pas un minimum
de garanties donc je ne peux pas
fonctionner dans l'illégalité
donc ça serait faux de le dire car une
hausse aujourd'hui juste nous avons pour
mission de faire venir des touristes
pour cela nous devons mettre en place
des stratégies
donc moi j'ai appuyé ma mandature sur un
certain nombre de stratégies pour
atteindre des objectifs
l'objectif est un million de touristes
nous l'avons atteint en 2010 est le
nombre de touristes a augmenté dans tous
les secteurs en particulier dans le
secteur du séjour où il n'augmentait pas
depuis deux mois 10
nous sommes jeunes nous l'avons déjà dit
maintenant est ce qu'il s'agit juste de
problèmes de communication au sein de
cette équipe
ou bien comme on voulait moi
personnellement je voulais poser cette
question mercredi lors de votre
conférence de presse est ce qu'il y a un
problème de niveau 2 de connaissance des
choses d'appréciation des choses est ce
que l'autre tendance est le plus proche
d'elle frais de marie-jeanne n'arrive
pas à comprendre comment ça doit
fonctionner un comité martiniquais du
tourisme
alors écoutez moi pour moi les choses
sont très simples je me suis entouré
d'une équipe
j'ai gardé un certain nombre de
directeurs de de l'ancienne équipe parce
qu'ils avaient prouvé leur efficacité
quand vous regardez les chiffres du
tourisme
depuis dix ans on n'a pas besoin de
sortir de polytechnique ou de l'ena pour
voir que ces chiffres ont augmenté
oui j'ai recruté une directrice générale
à laquelle je fais entière confiance et
je renouvelle aujourd'hui ma confiance à
mon équipe et on parie lui c'est très
important ce que je vais dire et en
particulier à mes directeurs qui sont
des professionnels et qui par exemple
pour faire un organigramme sont beaucoup
mieux placé que des élus qui n'ont pas
les compétences pour ça aujourd'hui vous
dites je dit que vos collègues
aujourd'hui je connais santé compétent
pour comprendre budget par exemple
aujourd'hui je défends mon épouse et moi
je vais vous répondre je défends mon
équipe parce que cette équipe s'est fait
agresser verbalement pendant deux ans
dans des conseils d'administration et
aussi dans des bureaux et moi je pense
qu'on doit respecter nos administratifs
sont tous sortis sont à ce genre de
poste car il nous saoulent n'y a pas les
mêmes politiques à s'être abstenus lors
du vote eu aussi des socioprofessionnels
et un jeu marcel marrant par exemple
alors écoutez jean marcel marron
s'expliquera sur son son choix un qui à
mon avis n'est pas un choix technique
n'est pas un choix technique
il s'en expliquera moi l'important pour
moi c'est les résultats du comité
martiniquais du tourisme aujourd'hui ce
sont les stratégies que nous mettons en
place
ma stratégie a été de revière
l'organiser que vous dépensez moins se
déployer
le budget est toujours le même il est de
notre question parce que c'est pour
rendre eux mêmes par rapport à -15%
évidemment avec 2 millions de moins nous
avons des résultats plus qu'honorables
puisque nous dépassons le million de
touristes
nous avons une augmentation du du de la
moyenne dépensée par le nombre de
touristes nous pouvons encore mieux
surtout pour les décisions tout seul je
prends les décisions avec une équipe de
techniciens qui m'entourent et ans qui
jure j'ai entière confiance et à qui je
renouvelle ma confiance ce n'est que de
politique tout ça finalement
je pense que ce n'est que du politique
et c'est bien dommage parce qu'encore
une fois bas pays en chance nous ne
sommes ni dans le camp ni dans le
complot ce que nous voulons c'est
travailler pour la martinique
les martiniquaises les martiniquais et
nous continuerons à le faire jusqu'au
bout
merci d'arrêter se battre avec nos
karine rousseau car il nous sauve qui
depuis sa dernière intervention a appris
à ne pas regarder la personne qui
l'interviewent pour ne pas voir les
questions venir ce sera pour se
concentrer pour se concentrer ce qu'il
est très tôt le matin ça la bonne
journée pour noël et on va vous donner
le café pour vous aider à merci bonne
journée
[Musique]